et
[Musique]
l'egypte se prépare à faire face un
débarquement de shadocks sur leur
planète mais vous direz vous si les
shadoks pouvait aller au bateau de la
planète shadoks à la planète jbe
pourquoi n'allait-il pas directement et
par le même moyen sur la terre à cela il
y avait deux raisons la première relever
du second principe fondamental de la
logique shadok qui disait pourquoi faire
simple quand on peut faire compliqué la
seconde relevait de lois cosmiques
beaucoup plus sérieuse c'est que pour
aller sur la terre il aurait fallu
monter et que si on avait monté l'eau
aurait coulé et très rapidement ils
n'auraient plus les jbe qui les voyaient
arriver se disait long leur un tour
camouflant notre planète tirons des feux
d'artifice il faut dire que l'egypte y
avait des feux d'artifice spéciaux qui
faisait de l'obscurité et quand on les
tire edge ou on n'y voyait plus rien et
de nuit ils se faisaient encore plus de
nuit
et des shadows nous voyons que de
l'obscurité conti père a ramé vers les
espaces extérieurs et apparemment infini
du cosmos
ils rament air longtemps longtemps
longtemps
il le sait puisaye dépérit désespéré
puis se pardonner leurs péchés et le
marin shadoks lui même noyé sa peine
dans une sobriété exemplaire
mais un jour un pauvre marin s'écria la
planète que jbe la planète jbe belge tu
le voyais là vous le savez ça n'était
pas la planète jbe c'était quoi
[Musique]